you
let's make a green smoothie always got
to start the day with a green smoothie
part of the morning routine prep some of
this I've got spinach pumpkin seeds
blueberries some protein powder from 22
days nutrition
maybe a little greens from juice arrow
add a little ginger a little Hakuna in
their homeland so I don't have any one
specific recipe most of the time it
depends on what we happen to have on
hand we have like seven people living in
the house so it's good enough fur is
good for brain function nervous system
mood elevator who doesn't like a good
mood elevator some Omega threes
essentially you're taking tons of plant
food that's super nutrient dense packed
with everything you need to function to
your peak capacity and it's highly
condensed and tons of fiber in it so to
sit down and actually eat everything
that's in here is if it was a salad
would be totally overwhelming especially
in the morning but to be able to
condense it down into liquid form it's
essentially predigested so your body
doesn't have to work very hard to absorb
all the minerals and vitamins and
nutrients that are in here taste test
actually tastes pretty good not that bad
it's not it's not amazing taste wise but
it's how it makes you feel that's the
important so a good way to start today
in the late start it's freakin hot out
so the ad there's no way it's definitely
hot it's not although not as hot as it
was a couple days ago so for those who
don't know I'm training for this race
called settler I think that's how you
pronounce it Swedish the United States
we would call it Hotel oh the swimrun
world championships it's a swimming and
running ultra race that takes place in
the archipelago south of stockholm over
the course of one day you ultimately and
running about 40 miles and something
about ten kilometres six miles
but there's 52 transitions so
essentially you're swimming in these
cold waters and climbing up on rocks and
running across little islands jumping
back in the water running across another
island switch switch switch run swim run
swim run swim and it's been a great
experience as 50 to see what my body is
capable of
I haven't raised since 2011 this is the
first rate that I will have competed in
in five years so we're over here at
Melville Creek State Park which is kind
of my backyard training grounds
beautiful State Park land with trails
for just miles and miles and miles
incredibly beautiful picturesque so my
truck is sort of like a mobile training
unit I like it a bit pretty organized
high and tight a half million different
pairs of running shoes in here running
shoes for all different kinds of terrain
they're like tempo road running shoes
these are my trail shoes it's what I'm
going to wear today these are like
average running shoes those as well
have my backpack for hydration for the
longer runs my heart rate monitor very
important to keep here and then super
important which sunglasses am I going to
wear
all right it's true when I was 39 years
old on the cusp of turning 40 I was
fifty pounds overweight I had been an
athlete in college but that was very
much in my rear view mirror it was in my
past that was a junk food addict was not
taking care of myself physically
mentally or emotionally and I had a
health scare shortly before my 40th
birthday I decided to change my life it
didn't happen overnight
it wasn't easy it wasn't linear but
ultimately I found vitality through a
plant-based diet it really restored my
physical body back to health and
wellness 2017 Zillo and September in
Sweden will mark the return to
competition for me and it's going to be
interesting one of the challenges has
been when I was training for Ultraman
and epic five my life was a lot simpler
I didn't have that much going on I could
focus on training with a level of
intentionality that I just can't afford
right now I have a lot of other things
going on in my life a lot of travel
going to Portland tomorrow to give a
talk I come back for like two days we go
to Ireland to lead a retreat so
obviously those are not optimal
circumstances for training and I have to
be okay with that because I'm not
willing to sacrifice all these other
amazing opportunities that I have to
spread a healthy message to empower
people to help people in order to serve
this athletically
all right let's go to the beach a
question that comes up all the time is
are you just addicted to endurance
training and endurance racing and my
answer to that is no I'm not addicted of
running I'm not addicted to swimming I'm
not addicted to cycling because these
things don't track for my life they
don't denigrate my life they're not
destroying my life they are nourishing
my life
SEP 14 anniversary today I'm not
training should be thinking about soon
and I are going to do to celebrate
tonight
we're taught from a very early age that
we should live a balanced life that we
should eat a balanced diet but what is
balanced really mean and I put a lot of
thought into this like what is balanced
mean for me if I am spending all this
time out on the trail that I'm not
attending to other areas in my life at
the same time when I reflect back on my
life the moments when I felt most alive
training for these Ultraman races
participating in epic five the training
that I'm doing now writing the books
that I've written that's when I feel
most alive and those are not necessarily
balanced activities those are activities
that require an unbelievable amount of
devotion and dedication and focus and
tunnel vision so if you were to look at
my life in the micro on an hour-by-hour
basis or on a day-to-day basis it may
not look balanced because I'm spending
more time training than the average
human being but if you zoom that
telescope out and you look at my life
from 10,000 feet and evaluate it over
the course of several months or the
course of the year I think you will find
that it is very balanced it's just that
that pendulum swings back and forth it
will swing all the way to the side as I
go in deep to do the work that I do
ultimately that's fine as long as it
swings back and I make sure that the
important things in my life again my
relationships my finances my profession
my children all of the really key
ingredients to living a fulfilling happy
purposeful life that those are in check
so I think it's the approach that you
bring to the activities that enrich your
life and there's something to be said
for casting aside the traditional idea
of what balance is and embracing the
idea that going all-in on something is
not necessarily a negative thing in fact
that might be the one thing that will
bring you back to life and engage you in
your journey in a way that you may have
never experienced and
and gird your experience with purpose
with meaning in a way that you can then
give back and be a service I really like
making these videos I've got to find a
way to do it sustainably and the
construct of everything else that I'm
doing but they're super fun and if you
like it subscribe leave a comment below
let me know what you thought